okay welcome to the next video with your
12 of the default series I'm this deals
with two moose and reply to two deform
and these are the moves
d6 and three six there of course closely
related so we'll do this in one video um
first off start with d6 actually this
move has some yeah it's a tricky one if
you want to play the suggested
repertoire especially in regards to the
kings in yet because the six of them
keep some blacks options very much open
he can either still play a King's Indian
set up with the fianchetto or he might
go for quickie 597 set up which looks
like in a wood indian opening so it's um
it's a bit a bit tricky because what's
main move here or main moves Knight f3
and also if for the reason why c4 is
less popular here is the move e5 and
this is actually a bit tricky to play
for white the problem is that the
exchange here doesn't promise white
anything it's just an equal position
already you can look this up like even a
scar opposed to positive score here
amazingly it really nothing white should
play for um what else can do I do
I can play moves like Knight c3
which immediately gets the Queen out but
black gets a good development and I'm
always with some time on whites Queen
that's also the move Knight f3 which
might be answered with on with the form
Knight g5 land is the main move and then
f5 this variation is actually quite
interesting for black to play also this
is a Heinlein that has got more than a
50% score if you look at a huge game
database and it's not easy to play for
whites especially because of the
advanced pawn on e4 black sometimes even
gets a slight space advantage here so
it's um it's a bit annoying this movie 5
on what I can recommend if you want to
play c4 and you really need to play C 4
here if you want to get into the kinks
and your lines I propose what I
recommend here is a move d5 which is
rare but but interesting I'm a black man
mostly plays f5 here which is logical to
make use of the fact that the night is
still on g8 and then white could could
play a form F takes d4 93 96 and g9 g -
e - the idea that is to play Knight G 3
and maybe Bishop g5 at some point to get
the pawn back on e4 and and hope to
establish a nice outpost on that nice
square only form this is a an
interesting way to play if you want to
go c4 um I really advise to to look at
this because it's really a tricky line
it's it's it's very
difficult for white to play for instance
I already showed this but this position
I'm playing with white and you have no
idea what what's going on can be really
annoying so it's it's good to look at
something here please note that you of
course cannot play neither three with
our repertoire because black then simply
transpose this or can transpose into a
Kings Indian and you have the knight on
f3 which is well no problem but it's
simply outside of the things you have
looked at the King's Indian black f3 f4
or this flexible h3 line where white
knights often ends up on e 2 instead of
f3 so on in which to choose carefully
here another completely different
approach which is interesting and maybe
a good idea to look at is to simply play
if or in this position and after not f6
Knight c3 just play an e4 line it's a
bit unusual maybe but it's maybe a good
idea to to look at some line here
because what the perk defense or modern
defense is not the most difficult
opening to play from a White's point of
view maybe let's say g6 and then you
look at some interesting aggressive line
like F form or maybe Bishop g5 this is
actually the favorite line by Alexa
Dreier who I mentioned numerous times
already as a nice player to look at if
you want to build in t54 repertoire he
always goes for this line because he's
got the same problem essentially he
plays the same ish against the Kings
Indian and if someone plays d6 ok he
says forget about this I'll play play
poke through this defense from white
from right from the white side and I'm
happy to to take the center and play
some
aggressive moves here I'm fine since
after Bishop g5 playin and continue
should be seven and then white has a
choice between Queen d2 or even f4 which
is well just from the looks of it a very
aggressive setup it's maybe an idea to
to have a look at this this also makes
sense in conjunction with another
question what do you play if black plays
g6 if you then go for c4 which is of
course possible you have to think about
some lines here you absolutely need to
play this movie and in order to be ready
for it for the transposition to the
Kings inion so it makes little sense to
for instance play Knight f3 here after
which black easily can go back to the
King's Indian and you got a setup you
didn't want to play
um so 193 here and then you would need
to look at various lines for instance on
96 okay this is not a huge problem as d5
is better for white I have to look at
one or two lines um I can show show the
best one quickly or one of the best
wants this line for instance is simply
better for white because Queen and
Bishop are misplaced um okay let's
return eeeh are more dangerous re5 which
you need to look at can be can be
interesting so black to play and also
which is very tricky 97 not played often
but interesting and now you're at a bit
of a dilemma here because you don't want
to play a3 really in this position
because very often black has got ideas
to exchange this bishop
of course this is never possible in the
Kings Indian with a knight already here
for instance if white takes here now
black even has this annoying check and
this idea so a3 is not such a good move
here if you look look at this in more
detail you will find out that actually
on all strong players go from 93 here
and then play can easily transpose again
into a Kings Indian with not on f3 it's
not such a big deal because black has
already committed to the line with 97 so
this would be just one line to look at
but it's it's really it's it's quite a
lot of stuff to at least have an idea
about and if you decide on on d6 to play
for reform then you also have an
automatic good reply on g6 as you then
just go for this and then as suggested
f4 on Bishop g5 of course you can also
choose another line like Bishop Bishop
e3 or we should c4 or something it's
just a matter of taste it's it's maybe a
good idea to pick some line against the
modern and the Polk defense and go for
this as it avoids a lot of trans
positional problems um there are some
some others little issues here for
instance let's let's say this and c4 and
what do you play now like oops black
plays f5 it's not very threatening or
something but then you are pretty much
forced to play a main line of the of the
Dutch Leningrad which maybe you don't
want to play in the first place it's
it's a bit of an annoying move
so it's a it's all fine if you study all
this little move or the wrinkles here
but I think it's it's really a good good
solution to to opt for this and just
just play a perk here okay one line
black is able to play of course is a
five here there you would need some same
idea as well one one possibility here is
to look quickly at the main line it's
not a huge body of theory or if you want
to play real aggressive here you can
also even go for for this g4 move which
is very aggressive um it's I think not
you you won't get this position too
often if you allow this transposition we
won't go into details of G form but it's
it's an interesting option to deviate at
an early stage to get a sharp position
um okay this is some really a matter of
taste if you want to go into all this
move all the things or just battle this
heads on with a form one line I'd like
to mention in this position is another
tricky little move if you play the
Samish against the Kings Indian which is
my main proposal here there's also the
most f3 here this of course has a little
bit of a damage flavor already if black
plays g6 now which he often does you
just go go for c4 and transpose back
into the Samish there are also some
independent lines like f5 d5 which
should be seven c4 which are rather
similar to the image set of the black
ass
Shivani seven this f3 move can be
interesting if you play the damaged note
that you cannot get into this if if
black starts with g6 of course
yeah f3 would make I think little sense
because a move like steer like g5 for
instance so it's a good idea to look at
g6 and g6 and some details as they are
they're really tricky to face yeah
thanks for watching this video and make
sure to subscribe to the channel if you
if you like it you get notified of new
uploads and it's completely for free ok
the series will be continued of course
and with more videos on dealing than was
already rather rare lines but as I'm on
on a vacation or playing a tournament
actually the series will continue in
about two weeks I won't be able to make
videos while I'm away so till then bye